c'est peut-être le sommet de la dernière
chance
objectif trouver une feuille de route
pour permettre au mali de sortir d'une
crise inédite et la tâche s'annonce
difficile pour la cédéao communauté des
états d'afrique de l'ouest
quoi jeudi dernier à bamako les
présidents du sénégal du ghana de la
côte d'ivoire du niger et du nigeria ne
sont pas parvenus à un accord avec
l'ensemble des composantes du mouvement
du 5 juin
l'opposition actuelle à l'origine de la
contestation
mais le président de la cedeao reste
confiant l'objectif est de trouver le
compromis qui permettra une sortie de
crise rapide
je suis optimiste je fonde l'espoir que
une solution sera trouvée le départ du
président bk est sans ambiguïté une
ligne rouge pour la cedeao qui est régie
par un protocole sur la démocratie et la
bonne gouvernance dans l'espace on se
dit oh si la démission du président
malien ibrahim boubacar kéita ne semble
plus être à l'ordre du jour l'opposition
reste ferme et réclame des actes forts
l'assemblée doit être dissoute et que le
prix de la ville fasse un acte fort pour
dit la m5
voilà ce que j'ai fait si vous faites
évoluer la situation
jusque là le président n'a rien fait il
est même resté ferme de la cedeao ne
nous impose rien n'est que le peuple est
resté là des boues
que pour trouver une solution le public
n démocratique
ibrahim boubacar keïta est pour sa part
resté discret il ne s'est pas exprimé
publiquement depuis le 8 juillet de son
côté l'opposition tente d'obtenir la
démission du premier ministre
la dissolution de l'assemblée nationale
et la formation d'un gouvernement
d'union nationale
en attendant un calme précaire règne à
bamako